president trump is fighting back against
big tech and today
he announced a brand new class action
lawsuit
against facebook twitter and google
watch this
we're asking the u.s district court for
the southern district of florida to
order an immediate
halt to social media companies illegal
shameful censorship of the american
people and that's exactly
what they are doing we're demanding an
end to the
shadow banning a stop to the silencing
and a stop to the blacklisting banishing
and canceling that you know
so well if they can do it to me they can
do it to anyone
and in fact that is exactly what they're
doing they're taking people off who
don't even realize they were taken off
they'd have no idea why they were taken
off
now with a team of high-powered
attorneys president trump is now taking
aim at what we have discussed at length
on this program that section 230
protections
now it's enjoyed by many big tech giants
because supposedly
they don't involve themselves in
editorial but in reality they do
but this section 230 is a legal
liability shield
and it protects these platforms they're
not content providers anymore they're
editors
from being held liable for the content
posted by their users
but they edit but now the twitter
facebook youtube
etc are all editorializing content with
so-called
fact checkers and everything who fact
checks the fact checkers
and warning labels even suspensions for
information
they deem inaccurate even when they're
wrong
or not up to their political standards
then shouldn't these tech companies be
treated like
any other news editorial outlet
after all even fake news cnn msdnc the
three broadcast networks new york times
washington post
they don't fall under the section 230
umbrella they don't have that liability
protection
remember these same social media
companies they censored
what was now we now know was completely
accurate
that was the new york post reporting
about hunter biden's laptop from hell
before the election why did they do it
to protect joe biden
and hurt donald trump you can't even
begin to quantify
in terms of dollar donations how much
in-kind
money that meant to joe biden's campaign
and now the president of the united
states donald trump is banished
completely
he is banned from twitter and facebook
and youtube
but guess who's not banished well look
at this
the supreme leader of iran that's right
the ayatollah khamenei
yeah he frequently tweets about oh death
to america
death to israel often calls for the
extermination of quote the jews
he is the leader of the world's number
one state sponsor of terrorism
at jack at twitter i guess you're happy
to have him
iran's mouthpiece president rouhani is
also on twitter he's also very active so
are multiple fake news propaganda
outlets run by the communist party of
china
a few months ago while conservatives
while yes a lot of my friends are
getting banned left and right
my team won't even let me have access to
my social media and have it for a long
time
but as conservatives were being censored
for tweeting about
oh the wuhan lab leak chinese propaganda
accounts were spreading
an insane conspiracy theory actually
accusing the united states and our
soldiers
of personally planting covert in wuhan
what in the virology lab they had access
to that
by the way at jacket twitter care to
comment and by the way notorious
anti-semite racist louis farrakhan
he's also still on twitter he's not been
banned
you know despite rhetoric about the
white devil
and the quote jewish termite virulent
anti-semitism is something fundamentally
wrong with a company that bans a duly
elected president of the united states
but gives an enormous platform to
america's foreign enemies and
other disreputable individuals and as
president trump just stated well if the
tech giants can censor the president
then there's nothing stopping them from
doing it to you as a matter of fact they
are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else